well hello everyone and welcome to our
lecture on the secret life of pawns so I
see a couple of familiar faces I think
you were here for last week's like
lecture about the secret life of puns
and I was talking about palm
breakthroughs and how even when pawns
were mirror in one another it was
possible to create a passer and to win
the game
well it was funny because it was almost
like just a day or two after that
lecture again a game was recently played
in Greinke a major major tournament
where Magnus Carlsen the world champion
was playing in our newly crowned
Challenger Fabiano car he won over
playing as well as six other really top
top grim world's grandmasters I thought
it was crazy that Viviano would
immediately after the challengers take
on yet another major tournament in such
a short period of time literally there
was a few days in between I thought he
was going to be exhausted his remarkable
echoes of the candidates he led the
tournament by half a point with one game
to go and in the last round he had black
just like in Berlin and the candidates
against Vitti and he won with black in a
petrov to clinch first so he's just had
two major back-to-back victories
tournament victories and he in one
week's well the 17th of April is the
opening ceremony I saw on the 18th less
than a week's time
mm-hmm fabbi will come here to st. Louis
and play in the u.s. championship so
he's going to have a very very very busy
psych schedule as he'll receive a hero's
welcome in this game Bobby was white in
green key and he's playing against the
world's number one ranked woman who you
fond and he gets into trouble but for
the secret life of pawns lecturer I'm
gonna go really really really fast to
get to this endgame position where Hui
Phan had really played a very very good
game completely outplayed
fabbi and he was losing so we're gonna
get to this ending all the way up to
move 62 unfortunately for who you Fon
she came very very close to winning the
game but she didn't put it away and she
had a really extraordinary moment that I
wanted to share and I'll get to that
position very shortly so who you Fon is
black and fabbi is white and we get to
this position
oops excuse me
so whites last move is obviously the
whole structure black here's on light
squares white is a pond down and is
desperately seeking to win a pawn back
so Fabiano played the move Bishop on c6
to b7 to go after the a6 pawn to try to
grab that one or to try to grab the pawn
on d5 now I think a lot of grandmasters
would if they didn't have much time
would play the same move that who you
Fon did which is she advanced her pawn
and the game continued and like I say
eventually
fabbi got his draw okay so this was a
crucial position and we were talking on
my first lecture about palm
breakthroughs and how often times you
sacrifice pawns to create a passer and
here who you Fon missed a really
beautiful win with the black pieces
thanks to a pawn breakthrough it's
nicely hidden and it's really really
cute so it goes like this
hui Fon should have played the move king
d2
okay if it's black to move well I mean
it moves like 92 and Knight takes c3 are
on tap so it's very obvious that white
is gonna take this pawn and again
try to take as many blacks pawns as
fabbi possibly can to make a draw now
so anybody see a potential breakthrough
notice that the King on d2 and the King
on b2 are in opposition
imagine if black had a past C pawn he
could go c3 Shack c2 c1 equals Queen
do you see a good mood d4 is a good move
and I could take that pawn on d4 though
and then c3 check and so we could play a
move like d4 takes c3 check a pride is
back up with my king and there's no pawn
break through here mm-hmm
so you have to be more clever
sorry here after Bishop takes okay
well of course in this position let me
do this haha let me see like yeah
all of these pawns are protected by
White's King so White's King as snug as
a bug in a rug he's got everything
covered and a bee probably thought it
was easy draw yes young man wait man
Knight to e2 very strong move indeed
Knight to e2 with the idea that after
Bishop takes to play Knight takes c3 but
here the problem is is a white just
needs to give up his bishop for the
pawns and it's not so sure that the
pawns are going to make it through we
need a tricky move Oh bravo Bravo
93 check a very very nasty surprising
almost study like move the idea is if
white captures d4 bishop on a 6 is
completely out and we can see that black
either wants to capture this pawn with
check and then advance or if you take
this pawn check and it's a girl you
gotta clean it's a girl ok let's go back
so as it turns out white cannot capture
the night let's imagine that white has
gone back with his King ok new main
light
now comes night 2 e1 Bishop takes Knight
takes if we play King bee to d4 again
takes the pawn c3 check now where do you
move your king where do you move your
King if you'll go to b3 you can go
Knight takes d4 check if you go to a 290
before check and once again all together
it's a girl so I thought this was a very
very nice pawn break through
well let's get back to our lecture and
the secret life of pawns
what is the ambition of ponds what do
they really want to do correct they want
to promote absolutely and back in 1981 I
want to say 1982 I was working with a
grandmaster from Reston Virginia his
name is Lou bar Luba Mira Cavalli
originally from Czechoslovakia Prague
now a Czech Republic and he was my coach
and second and we did a lot of work
together and he helped me a great deal
in my campaign to play in the inner
zonals
and Lou Bosch played a game that made a
very strong impression on me and I hope
it will on you so we understand the
ambition of pons is to promote but also
to advance up the board right it's just
such a such a nice one and this is one
of my favorites where the pawns are just
gorgeous okay so Edward befell the Grand
Master from the Soviet Union originally
from the Ukraine the Republic of Ukraine
is white and Lou Bosch is black and
they're playing very standard well I
want to say even classical rui Lopez
with c3 so we can see that white has his
ambitions he wants to advance this pawn
to d4 with the tempo clear whoa f5 ooh
where did that come from if you weren't
prepared to for move like that
that could be a very nasty surprise
right you didn't expect that move you
expected black to develop his night and
suddenly f5 so what will should white
play having said a you must say B he
played c3 with a very clear intention of
playing d4 let's refute f5 take upon ok
I mean who is this guy who's black he
doesn't understand when his pieces are
being attacked it doesn't move his
Bishop he took the pond and he's
attacking the knight another move that
you could consider is Knight d2
Jesus the light is a little bit too
bright yes there it is new new variation
so the idea is there's a trick can he
take the pawn on d4 no if you take the
pawn on d4 you fall for a double attack
tactic check and the Bishop on c5 gets
lost so there's a number of moves here
for white there's even the consideration
of playing Bishop takes c6 the idea is
that if you take the knight and
recapture with the bishop and maybe
white was a little bit more ambitious
than just coming out of the game with
material equality coming out at the
opening with material equality so Knight
whoops scuse me so Knight g5 was the
move okay
liubao had a cute idea just drop back
your turn now what you going to do
d 5 kicking the night really good so now
if the knight moves could somebody tell
me what's wrong with this smooth Wow
what's wrong with that
yeah oops it's not a smother checkmate
but what would we call this if it
smothered Queen trap its mother Queen
trap what do you think about Yes Mother
the Queen okay so Lou Bosch didn't want
to have anything to do with that
variation do you notice that what's
protecting the night on g5 what's
protecting the night on g5 the bishop on
c1 wouldn't it be fun to cut that bishop
off
now the night on g5 is under attack the
knight on c6 is under attack pieces are
hanging and blacks up upon what should
white dude what's he gonna do
where did this move come from just out
of the blue
now the the queen is threatening to
capture the knight and also notice that
this pawn on e3 is attacking the pawn on
f2
whoa there's a knight hanging on c6 as
well but you got to go for it right
because the knight is hanging on e4
thanks to the double attack of this one
and this one
that's what he did and then
that's what he did Wow and whites wins
apiece fantastic now because the bishop
on b6 protects the pawn on f2 it means
you can't capture this guy with the
Queen
so your king has got to move where to
move the King I think he actually chose
d1 king F I think Grand Master grew Feld
was worried that if he put his King on
f1 the rook on h1 would have been stuck
and remained out of the game Thanks
okay now there's a double threat right
so the double threat is he wants to take
the bishop but he also once depend the
Queen to the king so White's been
playing pretty good right I mean he's
made all the moves that you thought he
should and he's a piece up his King is a
little compromised and right now you
know with the exception of this pawn on
f2 blacks pawns aren't really going
anywhere
preparing to bring his Bishop e6
prepared castles with a check bringing
his pieces together so gu fell goes for
an ending guessing men it's black to
move here black played Bishop e6 and by
the way maybe Queen a4 check was in his
intention ooh that's a nasty one that's
probably one of the longest moves you're
ever gonna make in a game you go all the
way across the board and of course he
wants to castle as well so GU felt felt
that after Bishop e6 it was time to get
the Queen's off the board check so
traded Queens
kingi seven now from GU fells Bert's
perspective that pawn on f2 is a real
bone in the throat we got to get rid of
this pawn we want to play if white could
make these moves all in a row he'd just
be fine he all he needs to do is go
kingi to Bishop e3 and collect upon the
problem is is that King e2 is gonna walk
into Bishop c4 check
ooh that's gonna make it very very hard
to be able to play Bishop III so what
did white have to do at b3 protecting
the c-4 square so that after any rook
check he's ready to play king e2 Bishop
e3 pick up the pawn extra piece in hand
it's all good
also there is there is one other idea
that white may potentially use which is
to play Bishop a3 check attacking blacks
King so Lou Bosch did not develop his
rook instead he went Bishop to d5 with a
very nice threat
whoo Bishop takes g2 and all together
it's a girl
yeah Bishop a3 check King up Bishop Shak
pawn up Bishop h3 defending the pawn
okay what should black play now what
should black
look
rook a to d8 so after rook on a to d8
maybe white will play King e2 or I don't
know
92 not sure Rashid yeah I forgot to ask
which rook now we know he is the rook on
h8 and he's targeting that pawn on g2 92
takes rook takes man do you see these
pawns the beginning to look a little bit
threatening aren't they okay rook F 1 so
the idea was to stop Black's intention
black intends to go rook check and then
the other rook is gonna come over then
he wants to take this rook on h1 and
this rook would come down as well
so the rook had to slide over to stop
the that plan
so now he's just got Edwards night in a
pin and he wants to push his pawns so
kingi to breaking the pin right
what did white boy be for very strong
move just eliminating a potential
blockade well no choice here done it the
end of play space invaders soul video
game where the space invaders come down
the screen and you're trying to shoot
them before it the space invaders get
your guns well look at this it's a full
full assault bishop here the idea is
it's twofold first of all edward is
really really anxious for the
opportunity to bring his bishop around
and maybe on a good day
he's also looking for an opportunity of
playing c4 and c5 to try to trap this
Bishop f4
B for now he's got a different idea
ideas to put his [ __ ] and he's a rock
up once he puts his bishop there he's a
rook up
so what move did Lou Bosh play you ready
for a hint a moment ago he gave away in
exchange just so that he could advance
keep advancing those pawns what rook g5
Rep g5 Bishop c5 take it take it
so now he's an exchange and a rook down
but where are the defenders where are
the block haters f3 III e - they're all
coming down the board and after rook b1
f3 rook before he's trying to play the
move rook d4 as soon as he can
III check wasn't completely convincing
so III check what was the problem
no I think III check is winning the idea
is that Lu Bosch wanted to sidestep a
line like this you could take the rook
after King up you could take the rook
but then black would I mean white would
take this pond and then White King would
take this pawn and it's probably still
winning but there's some work Lou Bosch
played king of five now he's threatening
to go up the board rook d4 what did he
do take it and white gave it up the pawn
is is coming up the board III and II to
and it was sort of like what did white
do wrong he played all the moves that
you guys wanted him to do and then he
just got massacred by this pawn
avalanche that just at the end one two
three four all his pawns black ended up
with eight pawns like at three and this
game makes a very very very pleasing
impression where you know it's not just
about material but it's about the
quality of the material and in this case
what black managed to do was put his
pawns in motion and he gave up a piece
and two exchanges to do it and the final
position I lie
that very much eight ponds normally
speaking I don't get to an end game
where I have all my pawns still on the
board I love these kinds of games I look
forward to I look for them and I just
enjoy you know like when the pawns can
overcome you know the bigger the bigger
forces of the rook there's something
like that
[Music]